dans les vergers de plaisir la
cueillette des pommes touche à sa fin
anne-cécile cultive une douzaine de
variétés dans les deux hectares de ses
vergers trois de ses 12 variétés se
démarquent plus que les autres auprès de
ses clients la royale galal c'est la
pomme connu par tout le monde
croquante juteuse et sucrée après dans
ce verger l'abaya la golden et puis
lidar est parce qu elle se conserve tout
l'hiver une saison compliquée pour les
vergers qui ont subi la canicule cet été
grâce à l'appui du mois d'octobre les
pommiers ont pu reprendre le dessus même
si quelques dégâts persiste
typiquement les dégâts liés à la
sécheresse et toutes les pommes qui sont
tombés au sol
toutes les trois semaines bruno bien
remplir sa gâchette dans les vergers
un rendez vous indispensable pour cet
amoureux de pommes qui ne se voit pas
les acheter ailleurs qu'ici j'aime bien
pays remet pomme c'est des belles pommes
et filles elles sont moins traité d'un
commerce au moins faire aussi on puis à
le plaisir de la coyote pour mélanie la
cueillette des pommes est l'occasion
d'une sortie en famille habitant de
plaisir elle est venu en vélo avec ses
enfants et son mari pour cueillir ses
pommes préférées
on a pris des granny smith donc ce sont
les pommes vertes plutôt acidulées on a
appris aussi des jonagold très sucré et
légèrement acidulée plutôt à croquer
pour la plupart des visiteurs les pommes
se dégusteront seul mais seront aussi
transformé en compote en tarte ou même
en crumble
il faudra attendre août 2020 pour
consommer à nouveau des pommes cultivées
localement